it's time once again for our monthly
meetup Sony have revealed the seven free
games all PS Plus subscribers can
download from Tuesday July the 3rd this
month four of those seven games are
available on your ps4 let's quickly make
sure you are aware of the e3 extra game
call of duty black ops 3 it's available
to download right now but it will be
going on July 11th so quickly download
it ASAP
if you haven't already right now onto
this July's offerings
starting with absolvo this is a martial
arts melee focused RPG playing absorber
for a few minutes will make you realize
how different it is from typical
fighting games the RPG elements has you
building your own combinations of
strikes and parodies and dodges as you
fight computer-controlled characters and
more notably other players in the open
world after travelling to the land of a
dial you set your sights on becoming a
peacekeeper and we all know the only way
to become a priest keeper is by beating
the crap out of everyone you see as we
progress we'll dive headfirst into MMO
features such as solo campaign missions
cooperative quests and player versus
player matchups our rewards are
plentiful with new gear to unlock from
armor to improved combat styles and
weaponry and they're all usually found
on dead foes other weapon types are here
but they have both an advantage and
disadvantage for example they may do
more damage but they may make you slower
- absorber was very difficult to review
probably because of those MMO elements
the reviews I checked ranged from 6 to
about eight and a half out of ten they
attempted to try it I'd love to know
your thoughts next up on our ps4 is
heavy rain first released on the ps3 in
2010 this is the ps4 edition with
updated visuals and a few mechanical
tweaks if you played beyond 2 souls a
few months back you know exactly what to
expect and if you're playing Detroit
become human then consider heavy rain
its grandfather heavy rain is the story
of the origami killer who kidnaps
children and leaves them to die it's a
real feel-good game in all seriousness
it's the most depressing game I've ever
played but it's deliberately done that
way playing between the father of the
kidnapped son a private investigator and
the journalist looking for a scoop on
the story heavy rain will have you
playing from all perspectives there's a
ton of endings to see - and it's even
possible for the main characters to die
heart
we're through the game the rest of the
game continued without their input
making small decisions extremely
stressful back in 2010 heavy rain
received eights and nines out of ten but
due to the general progress in the games
industry the ps4 version received around
seven out of ten will you be pressing X
to Jason over on the ps3 is Rayman HD
I'm not completely certain which version
of the game this is as Rayman HD is used
for about four games in the series it
could be a collection of Rayman titles
but I'm not certain but if I choose
wrong I'll make sure to pin a comment
below
in my opinion Rayman HD will most likely
be Rayman three hoodlum havoc as the
title suggests is the third game in the
series which is much more lighthearted
than the previous games in this
platformer you will attempt to stop
andrei an evil black alum from taking
over the world back in 2003
it receives scores as high as 83 out of
100 next on the ps3 is extreme exorcism
but don't worry the title is the
scariest part of this game using a retro
art style you'll battle through a
haunted house full of creatures and
threatens in a pseudo action platformer
you won't be using a Ouija board to get
rid of the ghosts you'll be using rocket
launchers and Sods the six people that
bother to review this gave it 74 out of
100 on Metacritic the first title over
on the beta is also available on your
ps4 it's space overlords first released
in 2016 which tasks you with destroying
planets here's the blurb for brothers
known as the overlords have been
imprisoned by the evil Cassidy on you
and your brothers must rise up and purge
the evil contaminating the planet the
ps4 version supports local multiplayer
by the way will you be trying this one
you'll be creating sharing and
destroying planets and to end here's a
game with a ridiculously long title zero
escape zero time dilemma this world is
an adventure title consisting of
multiple chapters it's part of the zero
escape series and is a prequel to 2012
virtues last reward expect loads of
moral decisions to make as you track
down zero a good old masked kidnapper so
that's all seven games to get your teeth
into oh and there's also a new character
skin and back bling in fortnight battle
royale what so what would you say this
must be was kidnap and destruction are
you happy with this monster tails or are
you little underwhelmed please share
your thoughts in the comments I'm Adam
from Playstation grenade it's been a
pleasure see you next time